EU leaders wrapping up their summit in
Lithuania they're all smiles for the
cameras but the MTG failed to achieve
its main go an agreement that would
bring Ukraine into the EU fold ukrainian
President Viktor Yanukovych refused to
sign the deal despite last-ditch efforts
by European leaders to persuade him
overnight that's prompted anger the EU
has blamed Russia EU council president
herman van rompuy used unusually harsh
language the union will continue
insisting that any Russian actions aimed
at influencing Eastern European partner
countries sovereign choice is would be
in breach of the Helsinki principles of
the OSCE Yanukovych says he may be
prepared to sign the EU deal in the
future and Europe isn't keen to burn any
bridges the door is open we'll discuss
matters of concern that Ukraine may have
and we are ready discussed them with
Ukraine with Russia or whatever country
it was not all failure Georgia and
Moldova have initialed partnership deals
with the EU that means in future more
access to the European market for the
ex-soviet republics it's a historic
moment for both countries